good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the 12th edition of the ftth
conference good morning also and welcome
to this venue Expo 21 warszawa it's
great to see that so many of you have
made it here to discuss the only future
proof broadband solution for Europe
fiber to the home and the opening show
was just one example of how impressive
it is when telecommunications connect
people and businesses I agree what a
great battle at the beginning and yes
you won because you have a fiber
connection I don't have it so I didn't
win the race it's just a bit more than
60 years ago the european coal and steel
community was founded with a project to
create a united Europe working together
on an industrial commercial and social
level in order to make war no longer
possible on our continent and I think we
can be proud of the outcome the European
Union Nadia I'm also sure that you're
proud that the initiator of this project
Robert Schumann was a French minister
yes how did you know this was not the
only French idea that was adopted by the
whole of Europe think about the
revolutions against the absolute
monarchs on our continent and our
well-known national motto liberty
equality fraternity which fits really
well with the telecommunications of the
21st century I think that no other
technology has ever matched the Internet
in enabling people to connect and to
communicate in such a free and open way
good point Nadia and at the same way
that coal and steel united Europe in the
1950s broadband has the potential to
connect the continent today this is
something we all together really need to
work on all European citizens
have the chance to connect to superfast
future-proof broadband networks based on
fiber by removing the bottlenecks of
broadband connectivity we paved the way
the digital society on our continent
there's a lot happening in Europe on
this topic don't you agree Nadia indeed
the new European Commission and made
some significant announcements on
broadband and on the digital society
when they took office in November last
year the younger investment plan could
trigger up to 40 billion euros of
investments in fibre network and two
commissioners were appointed to cover
the topic of telecommunications so I
think this is a strong signal that
broadband is very high on the Brussels
agenda yep and let's just hope that they
find a good way of splitting the
workload and work together at the moment
they are very busy and nadir of posts
could make it to the fth conference
today but Commissioner Athena made sure
that his messages are spread here in
vaasa our keynote an Ohana he wrote will
give us insights on the European
Commission point of view on broadband in
her keynote later on and let's hope also
that fiber to the home will no longer be
a rude word in Brussels because outdated
the the outdated technology neutrality
paradigm remains a real hurdle to fiber
progress in Europe and we are quite
adamant at the ftth cancel Europe who
are quite adamant on this point market
players are free to choose any
technology but when public money is
involved only future-proof solutions
should be supported and nobody should be
allowed to waste taxpayers money on
solutions that will be outdated in three
to five years I fully agree with you
Nadia now at this point halfway through
the period of the digital agenda for
europe
we have the unique opportunity to review
the targets and make them suitable for
what broadband demand really will be in
2020 this review should start with a
serious look at the digital divide in
Europe which is a result of the
broadband targets in the ticket Digital
Agenda indeed who has the power to
decide if you only qualify for 30
megabit second-class internet or if
you're a lucky 100 megabit target winner
I live in a rural area in Austria I
cannot accept the decision makers tell
me it's my fault that I can only qualify
for certain megabit second-class
internet that I am just stupid because
I'm living on the countryside hmm vig I
know this issue of fiber in rural areas
always makes you very passionate but
it's true it is a real challenge for
Europe to ensure that all citizens get a
decent connection so they can
participate in the digital society the
ftth Council Europe calls for action on
this point and we will work together
with the decision makers operators the
investment community community to create
a positive environment for the rollout
of fiber networks to everyone in Europe
actually our new operator observer
status allows the ftth cancel Europe to
even to offer even additional support to
fiber operators on the continent yes
Nadia that's right and I promise we will
even double our efforts let's continue
in the spirit of the founders of the
project for European peace and success
let's learn from the fun and from the
positive emotions and energy that
developed when people like our to gamers
play together across borders let's enjoy
borderless online applications and
services at home and at work let's
connect
people and businesses let's create a
connected continent sounds like a great
proposition and actually it is a perfect
transition now to give the floor to
decision makers so they can share their
views on the importance of broadband and
we have a real impressive lineup of
top-level speakers in our opening
session today ladies and gentlemen we
are proud and honored to have mr. Andre
koletzki minister of administration and
digitization of the Republic of Poland
right here at our conference Minister
Hilinski the floor is yours